[Music]
okay thank you very much my name is
Mukesh and together with me how we would
like to talk about the challenges in in
natural language processing in the
context of Polish and other Slavic
languages and that's because we feel
that there is a lot of there is a lot
happening in the area of NLP now but it
mostly concerns English and most
publications concerned English it's of
course natural because English has a lot
of a lot more speakers and then polish
but but polish and other Slavic
languages seem to be somewhat
under-resourced and under developed in
in the in the context of automatic
processing and I also feel that it's a
nice continuation of the previous talk
because we're going to get somewhat
deeper in in the context of problems
that concern Slavic languages in
particular in automatic processing so
let us begin by saying a few words about
us we are both involved in several
different projects and endeavors now we
are both doing research projects at
eep-eep and this is institute of
computer science Polish Academy of
Sciences it's in in particular the the
linguistic engineering group I'm also
involved in in consulting data science
consulting at SiC Delta and also at the
management team at Sage's which does
data science also data science trainings
and I'm also involved in postgraduate
studies big data postgraduate studies at
the Warsaw University of Technology
where I'm a program committee member and
also a teacher and my hashtag so what
I'm most interested in is NLP obviously
and machine learning and education
Miha as I said is also involved at
research projects that's EB pan but also
at the University of Technology and
they're also in School of Economics and
he does also machine learning and deep
learning and and and is an avid
programmer so so maybe to make the stage
let's ask how many of you are doing NLP
in in any way professionally or okay how
many of you are doing NLP in other
languages than English okay so that's a
considerable amount but also smaller
than than those who do it for English I
hope that that it will be also
interesting for you so let's start like
making an obvious observation it's it
was also mentioned earlier by Sebastian
in during the earlier talk that nowadays
NLP is everywhere and we have commercial
projects commercial products which are
potentially being used by thousands or
millions of people which need these NLP
tasks that were previously solved in in
academia they need it to function so it
has to be implemented in a commercial
product in a way that it works with
regular people so so for example this is
home assistance they need speech
recognition to understand what what are
you talking about
to them and they need probably question
answering to to correlate your answer
with with some your question with some
answer and it's so so this NLP is it's
needed in in b2b to see products but
also in in b2b for example if you are a
company which needs to monitor your your
brand on the internet wants to know what
what are the opinions of of your brand
or your products on the internet and you
would like to
automatically scan these opinions and
Facebook mentions or honor other social
media then you would need such NLP tasks
as sentiment analysis or named entity
recognition to actually recognize that
they are speaking about you and maybe
conference resolution to to analyze more
complicated sentences but there are of
course many other tasks such as event
identification sense disambiguation or
information extractions are also very
much used everywhere now commercially so
this is happening but it's it mostly
concerns English and there are many
problems with with processing other
languages and especially Slavic
languages which makes it more difficult
and we don't see so many products and
implementations in in this in these
languages around so let's see what what
these problems are so at first there is
inherent difficulty in Polish and other
Slavic languages that is they are highly
inflected so there is this linguistic
notion of of a morpheme that a word
consists of something called morpheme
and this morpheme is can encode actually
several different meanings and that that
leads to ambiguity and ambiguity is the
main source of difficulty in processing
natural language so for example if we if
we look at the word Kovac which is human
now if we have an an inflected language
that that means that we have the
phenomenon of declension and one
consequence is that we will have very
much larger number of possible word
forms in a language corpora corpus then
for example in English because these all
these
all these forms in each of grammatical
case may appear in a corpus and this
multiplies the number of possible world
forms for this particular word another
problem is this ambiguity that several
forms are shared between different cases
and grammatical numbers so for example
trevecca may be the genitive case or
accusative case and you cannot really
tell by looking at the word itself which
case this is and of course there is also
another problem with the proper word
hamana me so a proper word hamana me is
the problem that the same word in its
nominative may encode completely
different meanings it's only it's only
an encoded in in the same way it's
written in the same way but it's
actually completely different meaning so
we have a de mirror here which can
either be a novel rank or a specie of a
butterfly and these two words may share
some word forms in their declension
tables but and this leads to another
form of ambiguity so so we don't know
which case this disease or even which
actual word we are talking about here
another problem polish has a free word
order and that means that in where in
the case of English you can say John
laughs Mary that that's about it in
Polish of course this most standard form
where you have subject and verb and
object is the most common Yanko hamari
but you can also say young Maria Cara
Maria carry on and so on all these
possibilities are our okay
linguistically speaking they are less
often but they are not
errors in any way and they often appear
in spoken language or or in informal
speech so we have to take this into
consideration and having this free word
order
many fixed context systems like HMMs
which take this fixed order of words as
granted do not work here very well so
another problem we have to cope with so
let's take this to a specific example of
one of NLP tasks part of speech tagging
part of speech tagging is a task of
marking up words in text with
corresponding corresponding parts of
speech so if you remember from from
school that dog is a noun that would be
the simplest form of part of speech
tagging but in reality we need a more
complicated tax set because we also want
to encode such information as what is
the tenth of a particular word or what
is the grammatical number so even in
English we have a tax set of of at least
36 tags to choose from and we use these
tags to to encode each of the words but
in Polish this is 100 times more
complicated so to magnitudes to two
order of magnitudes more complicated
than in English because in Polish we
have 4000 there are theoretically
possible tax so this a highly inflected
character of Polish and other Slavic
languages as a consequence creates the
situation where we have this tax set
which is two orders of magnitude larger
so the similar situation happens in
Czech and in Slovene where we have two
thousand possible tax so even looking at
that you can probably predict that using
machine learning to solve this task is
very much
more difficult so how does this tax it
look like in Polish it's it's positional
so where we had in English single tags
like an N to encode the particular part
of speech in Polish we have a sequence
of tags and first part of this tag is
it's a grammatical class where we have
35 possibilities but the next positions
are attributes of this of this
grammatical class and some of them are
required some of them are optional and
multiplying all these possibilities
leads us to this number of 4,000
possible tag values in fact only around
1,000 appear in in real world corpus but
it it is a lot as you can tell you can
also see at this example in the case of
of this ambiguity so if you have the
word mom you cannot really tell whether
it is mama or mommy or me edge looking
at the word itself you need to look at
the wider context to disambiguate this
this particular word so this is this is
the example of the problem mentioned
earlier as a bonus we also have
segmentation ambiguities when we look at
word segmentation they are not very
common but because of the way Polish
works and how the tux it is constructed
the the sentence search is Rob U which
is very simple only two words may be
either interpreted as what have you done
or did he do anything so the way you
look at it it may mean completely
different things you need also the it is
also the obligation of the tagger to
make this distinction and look at even
wider context to tell which segmentation
is is the correct one
so when we look at the real realistic
accuracies of existing taggers we can
see that these problems translate to a
big difference between English and
polish so in English current accuracy of
taggers is exceeding 97% in Polish the
state of the art in in 2007 was that the
best tagger which was rule-based had
around 88% are tagging accuracy it in
2010
britta girl was adapted to the Polish
Brill tagger is a simple algorithm which
works very well for English but in case
of Polish it only allowed us to achieve
around 89 tagging accuracy and 2012 we
gave us several taggers which used
various datum and various machine
learning approaches to solve this task
there were a memory base tagger and at
least two conditional random fields
based staggers and these this allowed us
to achieve around 91 tagging accuracy so
as you see this is not enough it's it's
still very much below this baseline or
[Music]
this amount that that English taggers
achieve so what we have tried in 2014 we
used this simple trick that is used in
in classification world that is we
combine several taggers together so we
used on sampling to to try to predict
these tags based on the answers of of
several individual taggers and because
the each of the taggers may make
different mistakes the theoretical
accuracy of such combined tagger could
achieve around 96
percent of accuracy if we could
magically select the correct tagger each
time a decision is made of course this
is it is difficult to find this
algorithm we have tried meta learning
which is not shown here and gives us
around 92% of accuracy
I'm sorry 93% of accuracy
when we do simple voting so we just
select the majority of answers as as the
final answer we we get around 92% of
accuracy but it is still not enough
because 92% of accuracy means that 8% we
have eight percent of errors so in a
corpus of 1 billion words there are 80
million mistakes so another problem here
is that we have very limited language
resources because when we use supervised
learning methods we have to train them
on some data and this data need to be
hand annotated so it's a very expensive
process when linguists manually tag each
each word and even tagging 1 million
words was no big endeavor and very
costly and of course if we had more data
probably these methods would give us
better results but it's it's at a cost
so what we have come up with we we
wanted to see whether making a coggle
like competition can help to solve this
problem so we organized something called
poly level which is in the scientific
world it's called shared tasks so many
researchers work on on on the same task
and and try to to beat the bassline if
you are familiar with coggle and so you
can compare it to coggle so we basically
prepared a training test we prepared a
test dataset which is not which was not
known to the participants and and we
opened a part of speech tagging task and
the sentiment energy
tasks and we had 16 submissions from
nine different teams and the first
surprising factor maybe not so
surprising was that all submissions were
based on neural networks and as you can
probably predict based on the type of
deep learning and so on
these deep learning methods performed
very well so while the previous baseline
was this CRF based agar which achieved
around 91% accuracy these new deep
network deep learning methods could
could surpass this this baseline by more
than three percentage points so the best
method achieved 94.6% of accuracy on
this test data that that we gave to the
participants and I wanted to highlight
the main differences between the methods
that participated in in the competition
because all the previous methods were
not deep network based they had
handcrafted features and in the case of
the new submissions they were mostly
deep neural networks some of them used
handcrafted features and one of them
used word level embedding so where to
work basically and actually this this
method was the best so this combination
of handcrafted rules and and word
embeddings proved to perform best so
what does it tell us
for one thing deep learning and where
the Mannings seem to be the key to to
really achieve high accuracy in this
difficult situation of a language that
is that has this inherent difficulties
in with grammar but you need a lot of
training data to really work with deep
learning and as I said polish is
limited resources language and some
questions arise for one which embeddings
are the best for for Slavic languages
should I use well too vague or maybe
some some other new additions to the the
choice of options here or should what
parameters should be used or how do I
even calculate and use the embeddings
should I use orthographic forms or some
other features that that I will base my
embedding zone so we made some
experiments on a completely different
task the task of event identification in
in text where we also had a deep
learning approach but we wanted to show
how the some some of the parameters
influenced the accuracy of of such a
system so starting with the size of the
corpus that you train your word
embeddings on you see that you need at
least 10 million word corpus to to get
embeddings that are really valuable for
your task so so this size of the the
data that that is available for you is
very important here another question is
what size of my embedding should be so
one of the most common size is it's a
vector size of 300 that it this is
indeed something that that gives us
result that we can rely on
but that translates to a longer training
time and higher memory requirements
another thing is how do we actually
calculate the embedding so for English
that the most common way is to use
orthographic forms but I as I said
earlier
in languages which are highly inflected
you have very different distribution of
words in a corpus than in English so
they are very much
they are sparser you can say so the
problem of small training data set is
even bigger because there are so so
different the world forms are so much
different in because you can because of
the fact that you have declension so in
this test what we have seen that using
embeddings on orthographic forms doesn't
really give you the the best results
that that you can achieve and for
example combining orthography combining
orthographic forms or I'm sorry
combining or ulemas with autographic
forms is much better or even combining
lemmas with part of speech tags because
you you take these base forms of words
which are more common in in a corpus
with grammatical information there is
also an example here with the first text
text vectors these are set to perform
well with inflected languages because
they take sub word information into
account so not the word as a whole but
but support information which is
important in in inflected languages
because of this notion of a morpheme in
and in fact this fact faster fast text
vectors calculated on the base on the
basis of orthographic forms and lemmas
and also using grammatical class
information allows us to to achieve best
results in this task of of even the
identification another question is how
is the original annotation quality in
in my data important when I train word
embeddings on grammatical features so
whether my data is hand annotated by
linguists or is it annotated using
taggers and to our surprise this was not
so important so that the size of the
corpus is some much greater influenced
and if the fact that the quality is
lower so we are but you're better off
using larger data set than very much
then using at smaller data set but hand
annotated in the context of training
word embeddings so in conclusions slavic
languages do pose a more difficult
problem in processing than than English
and some of the key points that we
observed was the size of the training
data for your task and for word
embeddings is is the key so so we have
to have a lot of data deep learning and
where the bindings are not only the hype
but they actually work very well here
also but handcrafted features work very
well alongside these dis embedding so so
your domain knowledge is still important
so you're still better of understanding
what what you are doing understanding
the language you are processing and
combining this handcrafted features with
embeddings it's also important to
remember that embeddings can be
calculated not only on the basis of
orthographic forms but also other
features and you should do that so so it
it really helps and you should also try
different embedding variants because you
have where to work you have laughs you
have give a fast text and that that made
it to to better accuracy and your of
course need a lot of tuning and hyper
parameter optimization so if you want to
try this on your own I will leave you
with some links that you can start some
are very well known
for example frameworks for deep learning
framework for calculating word
embeddings dancing but if you need
pre-built
models for polish that then you can find
them here
I also thank Sebastian for pointing to
our web page the web page of our team at
Japan at the earlier presentation so
this is this is still the same at the
same site if you need to if you would
like to see the existing tagger
implementations also those submitted to
pay level this is the official web page
and if you need textual resources in
Polish the biggest one is the national
corpus of Polish which is hand allocated
also Polish corpus of the 1960s and the
data set that was prepared for the
upper-level competition and also you can
of course use an unnoticed edge from
from Wikipedia or common crawl which is
a project concerned with with
downloading websites from all over the
world in particular language ok so thank
you very much and welcome questions
[Applause]
okay one question we don't have much
time but one question would like to ask
can you please comment on the state of
the art of okay so the situation is not
very bright because no one really
focused on the problem of the motivation
that there are some stammers there is
this morphologic stammer and lemma tiser
but they are not very accurate so
stammers are were not very accurate of
course but but the lemma tiser is is
rather simple and the problem is because
of the the character of Slavic languages
lammott ization is equally hard than
part of speech tagging so to achieve
high quality limit ization around 98%
you need actually the same process as in
tagging so you need to take context into
account various features and these
struggles that I was talking about here
they also dual amortization they do it
around 97 99 % but this is not a simple
tool that you that it's 100 kilobytes
and you run it from the console and it
works they are machine learning models
and neural networks so so expect to have
to download several megabyte model and
and so on and and it takes time so if
you want to perform limit ization high
quality limit ization it will take time
and you will need these staggers to do
this if you would like to make it
quickly and you are not so much
concerned with quality you can use
stammers maybe this morphologic limit
Iser also unfortunately we don't have
time for more questions but I think that
you can catch both guys on a break
coffee break in the whole day and
the evening so we welcome any questions
yeah okay thank you so much thank you
[Applause]
you